I'm JD lensen the inventor of fusion
knotting I've been challenged to go
through 15 levels of complexity with
knot tying
[Music]
level 1 overhand knot make a loop such
that what we call the Running end of the
loop is on top then on the opposite side
of the loop you're going to tuck it
through the back there's a lot of
variations that can spin off of this
basic knot the first is a stopper knot
where you tuck through the back of the
loop about three or four times then
you're going to pull the stopper knot
can also be the top of another variation
of an overhand knot called a square knot
we're going to take one side and go over
the Rope next to it and then around then
we're going to take my left side and
that's going to go underneath and then
around
going into the next level we're going to
increase complexity ever so slightly by
showing you how to make a bowline level
two bowling the way you do it you're
going to make a p the leg of that P is
on top of the loop then this end would
go around the body up through the p
through the rabbit hole and then around
the back of the standing end some people
say around the tree and then it cuts
right back down that rabbit hole
the Bowens a very useful knot for when
you want to create a loop that's fixed
but it doesn't cinch up when the loading
end is pulled on last thing you want is
for you to be in a challenging situation
where you need to be rescued and all of
a sudden as this helicopter or truck
tries to yank you out from where you are
you're fundamentally being cut in half
level three slip knot you create a loop
we're going to generate what's called a
bite just a bend in the Rope the bite is
going to tuck through the back of that
Loop and then we're going to cinch it
what sometimes happens is people have a
line on the bottom and they'll try to
tuck through the bottom and as you can
see it kind of just falls apart if it's
on the bottom tuck it through the Top If
the original Loop ends on the top I'll
get through the Bottom now a lot of
times people think a slip knot is kind
of an inferior knot because it slides
slip knot dare I say is even more useful
than a bowline or any other fixed knot
think about the sweater you might be
wearing while you watch this video
that's all basically created with a
series of slip knots the shoes that you
might have tied this morning those are a
series of slip knots so next what we're
going to see is how we can take a square
knot and make it slightly more elaborate
by tying upon itself in a form of a tie
that's classically called the Solomon
bar but more recently called a cobra nut
level four Solomon bar
so what we're going to do is create a
byte then we're going to split those
chords left and right take our right
chord we're going to cross it over the
two lines then we're going to drop our
left chord over that line and then tuck
it through the back
take up the slack in that to make sure
it's nice and firm then you're going to
take your left line cross it over drop
the right line over the top tuck it
through the back
then tighten that up and you have your
first overhand knot around the two
middle cords you're going to continue
forward Crossing that right cord over
the two lines next to it dropping the
left cord down over it and tucking it
through the back you're going to
continue this technique just as before
it's all of Embark it'll be a belt be a
necklace a bracelet so many different
utilities
next up a real clever way of taking a
slip knot and turning it into a linear
line level five the zipper set it you're
going to make a bite then you're going
to go right over left and then you're
going to take another bite and you're
going to tuck it through the loop and
I'm going to do something kind of slick
from here you're going to take the fixed
end and you're going to slide that
through the loop but before I tighten it
with the sliding cord on this end I'm
going to pull this out slightly then I'm
going to create another bite that
punches through and I'm going to pull
that one taut so moving forward all I
got to do is make a bite with the fixed
end slide it through the loop then cinch
it down and it creates this really
beautiful almost organic looking leafing
structure As you move down and I'm going
to create what's referred to as a double
overhand knot
now the reason why we call this a zipper
Senate is best explained to you through
demonstration you untuck it
and then Watch What Happens
one of the things I really like about
not telling in general is a few of them
go from a usefulness back to the chord
with a single pull you come to recognize
that these tools have so much
opportunity to generate so many
different things level six the Truckers
Hitch you're going to take your line
it's going to be fixed off at one point
then make an overhand Loop and you're
going to create
a slip knot this slip knot is fixed on
this end it slides on this end but
that's okay then what you're going to do
is take your other end and you're going
to fish it through
that Loop this right here becomes where
the mechanical advantage is achieved now
once I get the sufficient amount of
tension all I have to do is just take my
thumb and then create what's called a
half hitch now that one half hitch will
lock this Trucker's Hitch in place but
just to be sure I'm going to do the same
thing in Reverse what that's going to
create is a full hitch so I went from a
half hitch to a full hitch with a line
in series creating a Trucker's Edge now
a Trucker's Hitch is achieving a
mechanical advantage by creating a
series of pulley points without the
pulleys so if you're strapping something
down a Trucker's Hitch is really the way
to go going into the next level we're
increasing complexity by adding two
ropes together level seven bends a Bend
is fundamentally when you want to
connect two pieces of line or rope
starting off I'm going to show you the
fisherman's knot you're going to take
one of the lines and place it in front
of the other line in opposite directions
go over the line next to it and then
itself and this is very important
because you don't want to come up
between the two and then through
the loop that you've created look
familiar it's an overhand knot you're
going to cinch that tight then you're
going to look at your other side you're
going to do the exact same thing in
reverse
once you create these two overhand knots
in opposite directions you pull the load
they slide into each other so this
it's a great way of adjusting the length
of the cord or necklace around your neck
in some cases you might find yourself
needing to connect two pieces of line
that aren't the same size we're going to
make a six with our green rope we're
going to make a nine take the six and
put it on top of the nine you're going
to go down and then up through the
middle and then here it's going to go up
and down through the middle of that Loop
once you've generated this configuration
you're going to pull your standing ends
to create a zeppelin Bend and then when
you're done you can separate the row
pens with ease when I'm tying a
practical knot like a bowling and a
zeppelin Bend I find the utility really
inviting but there's nothing that really
draws Me In from a cultural perspective
when we talk about more decorative knots
or pieces that have spiritual or sacred
significant those draw my attention
they're like acquaintances that I miss
and in some cases want to celebrate
level eight the double coin
there's so many elaborate decorative
pieces that can be created from the
double coin knot it's also the base of
many traditional knots from Mesoamerican
cultures Germanic culture Eastern Asian
cultures and the British Isles I'm going
to start at the middle of my rope I'm
going to make a P with the left side
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to take the right cord and I'm going to
cross that eye just like a finger in
front of your eye then this end is going
to go under 0.1 then over 0.2
under 0.3 over itself and then under
that last point on the bottom you can
see that diamond pattern in the middle
but I want to point out that I didn't
fish for the end of my rope I just took
a bite and threw that bite through then
I pulled it out it's a little trick of
the trade or our next level we're going
to take the double coin knot and we're
going to expand it longitudinally as if
two coins overlapping wasn't enough
level nine the prosperity knot the
prosperity knot is kind of a clever not
it's a historical knot in the sense that
it's been around for quite a long time
but its structure is very similar to
Fusion 9 so in a way it is kind of a
historical Fusion knot now as far as its
utility is concerned that's really up to
someone's creativity to transition a
double coin knot into a Prosperity knot
you take your running ends and you're
going to pull those out to the side then
you're going to take up a little bit of
slack I'm going to pull that down and
I'm going to take up a little bit of
slack on this side what that'll generate
is kind of like these Wings on the
bottom then what you're going to do is
you're going to take this bite that's
down here and you're going to go left
over right I'm going to go over to your
left side and repeat the same thing so
then you're going to take this Loop and
it's going to go underneath the left
edge of the loop next to it this rope is
going to travel over the eye of that
Loop below and then you're going to fish
this over that rope end and through the
bottom of the end next to it and it's
going to create this kind of
configuration now all we have to do is
take our left side of our rope we're
going to go under 0.1 over
0.2 under
0.3
over 0.4 and under 0.5 I'm going to pull
that through to generate what is
referred to as the prosperity dot is it
a decorative knot yes can it be used for
utilitarian purposes absolutely once you
understand the fundamentals of the weave
you can actually reorientate it into a
variety of configurations while we're on
the subject of decorative knots that are
sacred to various cultures I thought it
would be really interesting to show a
knot that's referred to as a snake knot
Level 10 the Mystic snake nut you take
your top chord here and you're going to
make a loop then you're going to take
your bottom cord and line it up with
that Top Line of the loop and then this
right here is going to punch through and
generate you guessed it a slip knot
you're going to take your right cord and
you're going to curve it to the left all
the way around the piece then this chord
here is going to come around the back
and then down the left side
then you're going to take up the slack
tightening it nice and firmly then
you're going to continue forward just
like that this particular piece a lot of
the technique is in the adjusting making
sure each knot as you stack it on top of
each other is adjusted proportionally to
the one below it if one knot is loose
and the other knot is tight you'll
notice a difference I'm going to show
you how you can transition from this
color this yellow to the orange beneath
it the way you do that is you press the
yellow pieces to the middle and the
orange pieces to the outside and you're
going to do the exact same technique
except now you just change the color
this is one of the first times I'm
illustrating a knot that you could spin
your own creative input into the details
the nuances it's your choice your
Creative Vision
I finish it just a square knot snip it
there
torch glass those ends
and then you have this tucks through
and there you have it Mystic snake knock
made into a bracelet so now we're going
to move into the advanced knots where
we're going to take sentence and slip
knots and overhands and square knots and
we're going to mix them all together to
make something more elaborate more
detailed and more complex level 11 the
spindle fiber bar the name comes from
during cellular division there is
something called spindle fibers my
background is biology and so when I was
looking at the way these interlocking
hitches looked it looked a lot like
spindle fibers to me first you're going
to take two lengths of cord my Blue Link
is about six feet and this one's about
three feet I'm going to bend or Short
Line creating a bite at the middle of
the cord then I'm going to take our long
line put it behind I'm going to cross
over drop this one down and then I'm
going to tuck that through the back and
this fundamentally is just an overhand
knot wrapped around two parallel lines
then I'm going to take a cord on the
right side hook it underneath the cord
adjacent to it and through 2 The Loop
created and that is just a half hitch
now notice I don't tighten that up yet
we're going to leave that loose for now
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to take the line on the left I'm going
to go over the line next to it
I'm going to fish for the end and I'm
going to go down the loop associated
with that half hitch on the right and
I'm going to go up
so I've created another half hitch but
this one goes over behind and then up
through and this one goes under over and
then down through so this demonstrates a
little subtlety about half hitches just
because they're half hitches doesn't
mean you can't do them two different
ways this same technique is repeated all
the way down and so once again the
complexity isn't in the actual technique
but as the pattern extends itself it
starts to create something synergistic
so the hole is bigger than the parts
just like before we're going to snip off
those ends take our torch
and with the center strands I'm just
going to do
a double overhand knot
I guess as a side note I always like to
leave a little bit of tether at the end
for our next piece what I plan to show
you is a little bit more advanced and
spindle fiber bar but it's going to take
those fundamental methods in this case a
half hitch that may one day save your
eyes level 12 emergency snow goggles
your emergency snow goggles to reduce
the amount of UV light that enters the
eyes and subsequently saving you from
going snow blind start off with half
hitches stabilizing the base and then
full hitches along a right end line and
along the left hand line you're going to
take your right cord it's going to tuck
underneath the two vertical lines then
over
and through the loop created then take
the left cord and you're going to tuck
it underneath and then over and through
the loop created this is the middle
point where the bridge of the nose will
go then moving forward from here take
this line and you're going to go over
the two vertical lines above it and
through the loop then you're going to go
under the two vertical lines above it
and through the loop now doing over and
then under with a half hitch is going to
generate a full cow hitch it's also
called a Lark's head you're going to
continue this pattern moving up the
strands above until in this case you
generate six stacked full hitches as a
side note many people mostly encounter
cow hitch or a Lark's head off the
middle of a row but you can also
generate it as shown with a single
strand in One Direction you just have to
know how the knot is oriented same thing
on the other side and then to finish it
you're going to go underneath over the
top and through the lip created creating
a half hitch and I know you're thinking
this so I'm going to go ahead and say it
yes they can double as superhero masks
let's hypothetically say that you made
your way down from the top of that
mountain but you still have some
survival needs all you need to do is
just pull out that last Loop
and you have all your cord ready to go
and to be utilized for your next
challenge level 13 the backbone bar so
the backbone bar it's a counterclockwise
looped slip knot and a clockwise looped
slip knot that is sliding on two Central
strands this slip knot is going to be
the place that you tuck both of those
ends Accord through I'm going to flip it
over now remember how last time I did
the slip knot so that the running Edge
was on top this time I'm going to do the
same thing with the running end on the
bottom and I'm going to slide that Loop
through
you're going to tuck both of those lines
through the loop then you're going to
turn it over and you're going to do this
one on top this is kind of a cool
technique not only just for its
usefulness because this is the most
basic form of a backbone bar the
backbone bar is no pun intended the
backbone of other types of ties
now that we understand the fundamental
principle of the backbone bar I'd like
to show you the next level taking this
technique and utilizing it in the form
of a cylindrical pouch level 14 the
utility pouch so just as we did with the
single bar we're going to go ahead and
take this line we're going to tuck it
underneath we're going to bite that
through make a slip knot and the slip
knot is going to slide over the two
lines in front of it we're going to
rotate to the next position we do the
exact same thing I'm going to pull that
tight
we're going to continue to do this
moving forward it's like a slow motion
spiral made of slip knots to finish the
top all you got to do is widen that hole
just a little bit fish for your end
and tuck it through From the Inside Out
take my end this from the inside
to be out I'm just going to do an
overhand knot a double overhand knot
turn it around we're going to do the
exact same thing once you've generated
that don't need all this extra cord
take a little torch lighter
utility this goes in your pouch
and then this
goes around the belt
level 15 Bush sandals so the bush sandal
is an elegant combination of a lot of
the different elements I've already
shown you today we're going to show a
full hitch overhand knots and we're
going to have one of my favorite knots
the slip knot for each sandal it takes
about an hour and a half with a little
bit of leeway I would say about three
three and a half hours for both sandals
sometimes people have come to me and
said why would I want to make Bush
sandals when I can buy a pair of saddles
that's a great question if you have a
store nearby but in some cases you might
find yourself out in the bush and dumped
say for example in mud in one instance
that I personally had I was able to pull
my feet out but I wasn't able to get my
shoes out so I found myself with socks
and nothing else what you're going to
need is five 20 foot lengths of paracord
or any cord for that matter I made a cow
hitch at the middle of the four chords
you're going to take your rightmost cord
and you're going to go right over left
creating that familiar nine with the
loop on top tuck through through a bite
creating a slip knot that slip knot is
going to go over the cord immediately to
the left then you're going to take the
cord that you just wrapped make your
nine punch through your bite and go over
the cord to its left
and then you're going to cinch that up
you might be seeing a pattern form in
here you're going to continue this all
the way until you reach the leftmost
side once you've done that you take the
entire piece you flip it over and then
you do exactly the same thing as you did
before this is what your mat's going to
look like the last knot being tied here
we're going to take this toe and we're
going to compress it in and that's going
to be a protection for the front of your
foot it's also going to help kind of
lock it in place in the front you're
going to take your left cord and go over
your right cord to make an overhand knot
then you're going to tuck your left cord
under the right cord and over turning
your overhand knot into a square knot
continue moving up left over right and
then left under right and you'll notice
the front of your shoe slowly curling
over your toes
once you've generated the last knot
you're going to measure out an
equilateral triangle take a little tool
called a splicer go down in between the
knots just like that
this is going to come over the top where
you will tie you guessed it another
square knot
the sandals themselves feel really good
on the feet kind of like those beaded
backs that you put in cars and it
triggers kind of pressure points on your
feet it feels really nice
I do not consider nodding a few night
field study I consider it like poetry
you can reconfigure them in any way you
want creating your own prose your own
music in your own way as you start to
reconfigure what seemingly is simple
into more elaborate configurations you
start to see things start to emerge what
I'm showing you is not a finite field to
study it's really your opportunity to
play and discover